you
hi everybody welcome to another week of
me playing you so hopefully you've had a
good week let's dive into it do you know
how to challenge me
alright so please go on leeches calm or
sorry and challenge San Luis chess club
oh we already have some challenges
preferably something with an increment
maybe 3 to maybe 5 to something like
that but I also like funny names so
let's see who do we have huh all right
let's go for it's ok if you give me
casual or rated I don't really have a
preference
so what's diving
oh wow that's really something I'm used
to but okay
hmm
all right let's see probably you want to
continue with some d4 c4 I might regret
this later let's see
okay let's not lose the pond sure seems
like a I mean if c4 seems like your
weird English or like a reversed
efore c5 Knight c3 okay well how do I
want to I don't like this bishop here
let's see where it goes
Wow alright maybe I want to do long
castle do I want to do long castle yeah
let's see how it goes alright
probably Bishop g2 coming up
huh all right so a stripper service five
probably g4 let's not get into that trap
this should be nice something like my g5
might be something to look after but see
like what right now white can't really
do short castle anymore cuz the edge
strip is hanging so actually I don't
want to think about 95 so probably
something like d4 is worth considering
I'm not sure how well it works but does
[Music]
d4 work what do you think hi everybody
[Music]
I'm looking at the chats huh why yg4
well you don't want to play shorts
Castille I guess all right let's go for
the center I really wish I knew where I
want to put this night cuz if I put it
on f6 kind of closes off the bishop d4
do I want to take it yeah
let's close off the center so probably
something like we need to moving this
light c4 ooh
the c5 square is looking a little bit
ugly okay I guess I do have to make this
happen
yeah let's push maybe h5 was more
accurate then I would be pushing on its
tree a bit but if not that I can think
about something like f4
okay let's try this looks pretty fancy
if you take then drd4 is falling Wow
I guess if you don't take your d4 is it
still falling right take it clean
take this guy
do I want to push can i push
ah time well let's just take it
we gotta move this guy where do we go
yeah maybe I can hope for some d-force
I'm not liking this as much fact there
should be some sort of tactics coming up
okay let's protect now I'm gonna bring
the rope at my time I feel like if I get
a few moves to be able to bring out my
pieces it would be pretty nice right
let's do this
probably blunder hmm feels like it all
right
I am quite low on time ha piece nice
let's try to keep my pieces standing
taking thank you spring at the king
this is kind of really stressful I don't
want to lose on time my piece up oh he
got really close well thank you for the
game it was it was nice all right let's
move on to next one oh I see it this is
a funny name dr. Chung Chung Chung
gazungas
sorry I'm not the best with
pronunciations is this yeah well I don't
think he's available
10:10 is too much and we're never going
to finish that
okay let's move on
oh well thanks for making your move all
right
are you gonna do that me we're gonna go
for a real office yeah I usually just go
for the normal night of six and four
nights but I wanted to be spontaneous
today and I really liked Bianca towing I
don't really know why it's not that fun
ha can you take 95 no not this position
but yeah something to look out for
whenever you're trying to do this pen is
this taken night g5s hmm do I wanna take
it them or do I want to play Bishop
which five then you get to put g4 maybe
it's five take take Knight g5 yeah
you know what let's just go back
retracing is never a bad idea
position still looks pretty decent
I don't like this a five coming up but I
don't really see any way to stop it okay
I thought I would get out of the
position a little bit better but well
can't always get what I want
all right I really don't like this a
five so my queen is pinned I think it's
about time to move the Queen right yeah
might not be the best place because it
doesn't really serve much purpose but
now I can try some fancy stuff like this
try to pin this guy then if F for maybe
I can go for something like h6
or look at five I do you think I don't
think wise [ __ ] boy f4 oh wow
ambition before was interesting because
if I would take with deed and Queen d7
if I take EF 4 then like Queen D 8 and
it would kind of mess up a pawn
structure and I still think the endgame
is better for black but wise would have
good fighting chances at least so I like
this more alright let's try to develop
where do I want this Queen to be I feel
like this Queen should ooh
trying to go for f4 interesting
anyways I do think I need to activate my
queen
maybe I can try to go to like h5 and do
some fancy trick you have trees and hmm
okay going for my blood I see could have
made me take maybe I could have taken
Citroen take a stray probably that yeah
all right let's see what can why - I'm
so tacking h3 and next move I'm also
taking c2 but I'm not really gonna take
on c2 because I don't want to lose my
ecigs fun so I would try to do something
like rook e8 and then take on c2 but
what really has to defend a streak
because if not I will take on history
wow we're really going for my blood I
see why all right I have to come back
what it should be still okay I can't
quite rocky 8 and start playing
something like maybe a 5 I would prefer
it if my position if I didn't have to
regroup my pieces all the way back
honestly but
I could take on f4 I think but then
exchanging Andrew takes Isaac I don't
think that's the pleasant end game I
would want to enter
so let's exchange these guys off come on
I know you're gonna take it oh wow
why alright let's see let's go hunting
some puns
probably with g2o I am off with my move
detectors today
I'm coming I'm coming for G fat Oh
actually nope that's not meat
this however is winning bunch of stuff
and sixty-three attack in d1
oh all right let's take this guy coming
for d1 thank you
taking us a lot of time to bring out the
big guys right
I want to give a check here maybe give a
check on you on or just maybe dabble up
my rooks and see how that goes oh okay
let's double up the routes
oh thanks
yep
ah all right this was actually pretty
interesting so yeah the opening I wanted
to mention about this opening I think d4
is the most like straightforward way to
go because if then II takes d4 Knight
takes d4 like Bishop g7 I think that's
the most famous way to go but yeah this
was this got really interesting alright
let's see I do prefer hmm a little bit
of increments uh-huh I see some thing
Turkish alright let's play with this why
do I keep getting black I miss playing
white I like playing white scotch
now you get now I get 4/9 this is a very
smart way to transpose it back to 4/9
okay god I did this Bishop c5 is also an
interesting line but not really my top
choice and then we get to this very very
interesting endgame
I mean if everything goes right not try
familiar in the early Bishop g5 but if
something feels off
might just be in my head but why can't I
take this
oops mate yeah now I see why I can't
take it
oopsie happens to the best of us so yeah
another good idea is try to make your
King safe oh well I guess he missed my
deal on whoa
thank you let's exchange these guys
laughs before I make any more unintended
blunders all right
this attacks some stuff
take it thank you okay now I want to go
for good stuff over there
let's keep our King safe shall we okay I
see you're coming from my pond I don't
want to give my pond
alright let's give it a check over here
and another one here and take this guy
I do want to keep my pawn here so let's
give this a try if you take a seven I
take c3 if something like a for Brooke a
three so it looks like a need to trap
that works right yeah it works you gotta
push a five but you can't really push a
six oh no I gotta get a chance to bring
out my king
nice seems peaceful enough
Wow can't believe like skip mate
whoo-hoo
this one just makes it easy for me cuz
I'm gonna start pushing this little guy
my baby Queen one
to
you want to have my bishop here I don't
think it really matters if your bishop
is in center or not but it just I like
it more it gives me more opportunity to
control squares
maybe Bishop c2 was more accurate or
Bishop huh yeah this should still not
have a problem for me I'm just gonna
come grab your pawns please
all right thank you you if I'm you did
have mate
so thanks I think I mean let's just
check it again for our own eyes
here was the blunder you could do Rukh
t8 mate again well happens the best of
us let's move on
I hope I get white finally
[Music]
let's do this one again why we always
black did I choose this the right
setting god
all right now this is interesting it can
transpose to a bunch of different
openings depending on how you proceed
but yeah if C d-four then Bishop before
it's like the Italian but c 3 d 4 if e 5
now I got to play D 5
yeah this is the theory well uh Bishop
b5 is the stronger move and then 94 and
then he would take C d-four mmm
this kind of just gives me the pong
ah so the people who challenge me can't
pick the color make it random come on
I've been black all games so far all
right
let's see is there any tricks here after
last game all right I'm just gonna keep
the pawn and not get made it that's a
good strategy now let's see should we go
to and game already or I kind of want to
keep the game in the middle game I do
want to keep my Queens on it creates
more chance of attacks at least for me
some players love playing endgame I'm
okay with endgame but if I have the
choice between keeping Queen or not well
I prefer to keep my Queens 94 should be
coming up what would you do after 94
like h3 g3 probably
then maybe some 95 trying to oh I like
this let's go for this not a blunder
okay does anybody see any awesome
tactics because I don't
the 9033 Bishop of two was the awesome
tactic but I mean I'm thinking about
maybe something like Quincy five but 94
oops never mind
Quincy five something like we need to
Knight f3 kavita Bishop to Queen F to
Queen C 4 does that work I mean not the
attack I wanted but the problem is if I
play Knight e5 just Bishop e2 and
everything is protected so let's give
this crazy thing a try
yeah Queen e2 seems like the logical
move right because I'm attacking c4 and
f2
I mean feel free to discuss the game to
me I am reading some of the charts but
in my opponents time um maybe I did get
a suggestion on the chat from up to a
rod Bishop of to recap Sudan Queen c5
I already did play Quincy bad
yeah maybe 95 Bishop e2 Bishop e3 Buddha
works to rookie 1 and F 2 is too weak
should be falling but I don't think
that's the most straightforward yeah
Queenie to Pawnee tactic yes
alright might have to write night after
should seems logical because even if
something take that guy I take this guy
and I'm simply two pawns an exchange up
cool so now I can just try and play
something like Bishop h3 bring out the
rook it I mean it's still not easy peasy
but
all right let's attack your guy and then
I want to bring out my die
f4 is a good square but
probably bishop III yeah
building up some nice fortress over
there
alright one thing that I know that I
hope I know it right is that when you
have like two rooks two Wondrich try to
exchange off that's real one rook
I'm thinking yeah I'm probably gonna
start eating some ponds ideally try to
exchange more pieces off if I could get
this night with my bishop that would be
nice too
I was going for your pawns come on give
me the pawns all right let's be stubborn
about the pawns
now let's bring out the little guy well
the big guy in this case I guess you
going for Cee 7/7
yeah I mean I guess I don't have to I
don't want to you have to because if I
the wooden place is c6 then both a7 and
C seven hundred attack I am in the focus
mode that is true when I play chess
unfortunately I played way too seriously
sometimes it's nice sometimes there's no
weight this nice kind of this nice feels
trapped
maybe not trapped like trapped trapped
but trapped enough no no let's not give
that chance
okay the question is how can I keep
attacking this guy without weakening my
how can this guy scape
you know what I think this is a good
move I'm gonna go for it
I'm blocking on the g4 stuff I might
wanna play like they should be for
defense e6 a bit more
okay go away
Oh
Thank You Bishop d6 might have been a
better fight instead of Bishop III but
yeah I mean that game is better for me
regardless all right
I have some interesting challenges I see
a chess person let's go to chess person
Oh finally wait thank you I do believe
there are no increments so I have to
keep it cool and quite fast
I hate no increments hmm let's go with
this one
I do like this idea just because it's
first of all not very commonly known
usually second of all I get a nice flow
of my game in the queenside pretty
immediately
push
well one some idea that black has is to
try and push for the kingside but it's
not very easy to do to my experience
because like F at five I could I always
go like F to your F for but let's push
this guy at five let's go with f3 or f4
which one do we want to go with F 4 F 3
the problem is if F 3 then F 4 and this
picture is kind of not where you want it
to be if F 4 e 4 then this Bishop
becomes too strong but then I do have
this maybe 94 yeah let's give this a try
do you believe I think both of them are
doable moves but this just feels more
more me
nice move coming up
maybe maybe also a 5-2 take away any
ideas around here
yeah let's do that let's walk here first
now we want to go we've not see five now
I kind of have to take the night ac5 huh
well I mean 95 I could still know if 94
Bishop d4 Bishop d4 93 whoopsy
probably five was a little too hopeful
oh well thank you give me one more role
to play thief okay Bishop yeah okay
now coming up
all right I have to be careful I do not
want to have this nice bee tree in my
face so I think this is a good way right
tonight's kind of stuck there no more
nights p3 and now I get to do this
before
I am a bit worried but actually this
doesn't work so I'm not worried about
that anymore
let's move to stroke do you want or see
one skull D one let me see one maybe the
other one goes to c1
whoa where are you going
probably not g4 right why can't I just
move the Queen
no I don't really I'm not used to
thinking out loud just because Oh hold
on
I see tactics you take it I'm gonna go
d6 now take the rook gladly probably say
thank you yeah I'm not really used to
thinking about chess up loud so that's
kind of new to me okay you still can't
take this guy so how can I use that vc6
take bishop takes a six yeah mmm I gotta
do something
if you take c6 Bishop a six stake that
ah
well thank you I got to make a queen oh
well thank you for not making me stress
over time but yeah this this was pretty
interesting I mean this except for the
blunder I mean even here just taking
making queen taking back it's still
should be playable position even though
after Bishop takes a six I should have a
better chance wait Queen g3 take the
pawn maybe yeah it's it's not very easy
to multitask it's kind of do it's kind
of hard to read chats and look at this
alright let's see who else you got
alright I see
let's see is anyone requesting on the
chat all right I have a ok let's see
alright I found you
whoops my bad clicked on it all right
yeah that's the guy boot yeah
Oh
well let's take a look at this
usually I likes this would be five three
Lopez but I have good memories with this
hmm not that this I'd remember some
games that I looked at a while ago not
quite a while ago
and 93 was doable back then
let's see how this turns out
and don't we know what to do with the
bishop I think that's kind of the
problem I guess like this picture was
just hanging out here without any
purpose see and stuff like this happens
now some queen is 4 3 4 stuff might be
happening
whoops I have to look out for those or
not okay now I can think about something
like f4 take on d3 I take back and there
might be some bishops Wars or something
like that or I could try to go Bishop g5
try to pin the night first I like that
let's see how this turns out cuz
honestly what else am I gonna do with
this Bishop I don't really see any nice
diagonals that I would want to have this
bishop at
Oh three five percent III it's faux all
right
maybe g5h fire was a little tricky I'm
not sure if like how good it is but it
looks a little too suspicious oh I see
chats
I do see a person writing Reza we see
you just can't really multitask
how many line of what oh playing I don't
know it kind of varies between there
were the games I don't know I kinda
wanna do this a five and start attacking
but I don't think it's ready just yet
maybe if I take take take tonight I
really want this Queen to be out here
the Queen f3 there's this Bishop g4 do
you have to defend this guy
mmm it's getting tricky huh
all right well let's give this a try
probably not a good idea but yeah let's
see how it turns out
take take take with the night maybe
something like Bishop takes East 7 take
96 wow that works because if you take I
have appreciated 7 at another ahh
taking away my tactical ideas I know I
know it's cheap tactics but it was
pretty alright was trying to defend the
pawn
poof getting a little too feisty I see
attacking my alright it's about time to
get to that this night
do I want to continue with Queen f2
after or something like h3
let's do with Queen o Queen up to 94
Queen a for ya let's let's go with that
I might regret it it looks way too
interesting not to do it
this coin on d5 is really strong so
that's not something I would want for
myself
ideally alright so something like can I
do
nope can I save this nope not really
alright let's try to kick this bishop
off out away now g3 queen g3 alright I
don't like your knight over there
now g3 I take with Queen take this guy
can't really save the pond can i and I
can try I don't like this trying take C
3 Queen takes c3 Queen a to your Queens
way to act it for me to try to stop it I
think that's kind of the problem
okay one of the problems
I know if you don't take it I would play
c3 and defend the pawn now ideally I
want to get your king to the corner so
this
my pawns are crying in this game that is
true statements nothing I can do about
it now its pawns are horrible
really
cheap tricks
cheap tricks
well
well my pawns were crying that is true
who then I came up with some nice cheap
tricks let's see yes I did say that
there were cheap tricks yes
cheap tactics okay let's take a minute
and look at the chat to see five as
possible instead of efile maybe but the
the ether square was way too weak what
time control I think three two is nice
maybe five to something like that
ah let's see I guess that's all we had
for this game yeah let's see who do we
have a bunch of challenges
[Music]
I think I played some of you already
that are on the English challenge it's
kind of funny name let's go that's
pretty twister oh nevermind let's go
this guy
all right I went out of d4 today
name's Oh
let's go for nimza whoo I did this in
Panem's paid off
let's see
hmm d6 first yes
so my idea is to do something like a
five and do like a castle and ideally
try to do a five make a castle and see
how that pays off but not necessarily I
get to do that all the time
okay I do have to give up my pet bishop
I think this bishop here is pretty
strong because it's also taking away my
immediately v and there might be some
ideas with E 4 and then e 5 from white
side okay so before I gotta play e5
because if not then and why it would
play e5 what do we want to do with this
weird night here g8 b8 all right let's
go b8 we'll try to maneuver it back to
the game good old-fashioned way
I think something like a5 is a pretty
critical mu G for huh interesting
well well what I was trying to say is if
I get the chance to push all the way to
a four I can try to go for the c5 square
something like this maybe night H file
was good enough to then I will just try
to keep it here and yeah I kind of want
to deny - man whoops but anyways I don't
really think why it has such a strong
attack honestly at least not yet oh this
looks interesting if Queen takes a four
night before when before oops Queen
takes a okay hope we didn't take it for
so let's dive in going to be tree maybe
some f6 mmm not not if it's necessary
okay
yeah let's try to open up some squares
cuz what where does this King wanna go
along cast all probably so much fun I'm
answering my own questions right
yeah see I answered my own questions
stress is so much fun oh yeah yeah all
right I will probably regret this but I
love puns and I don't really see how
else can I make it work so all right
let's take this guide you let's try and
give some some cheap stuff here who does
this work actually Queen takes b3 there
what if it's 93 King moves Knight takes
D - hmm Wow
might work or the tribe may be queen III
was honestly stronger to attack the
bishop first and then I have the idea of
Knights p3 maybe all right let's see
what should you do
that was kind of a given honestly
alright now I gotta do something with
the Queen
f4 or e3 let's go all the way in
I feel like I'm leaving my king all the
way like empty but something should be
happening here on sleep maybe a knight
f6 Bishop g4 should be their
whistleblower movie night c5 Bishop c5
roopd - yeah or that
now I have Queen f3 or queen T for Queen
f3 there's Bishop e2 is there a show me
- yeah so but if Queen here then there's
Queen c3 I see this should be - I'll
just move the Queen way that's what I'm
saying there should have been something
there I just fail to find it
I mean I still have 94 coming up so I
mean I'm it's not like I'm still better
but I think my position looks more
advanced if I just had two more moves to
bring out the night on d7 and the bishop
on c8 that would make it even better
okay
were you trying to get my friend g3
probably all right let's try for some
nice old-fashioned cheap tricks oh whoa
I got cheap trick can I actually just
run away
I mean I'm still taking eat you I'm a
taking h1 all right well well sometime
but I'm actually not sure if this
position how is the values it looks like
I should be winning because I have Queen
B 1 I have Queen e2 i have queen and
schwann and the G something like
everything is hanging right yeah I don't
need the extra piece it's nice that was
funny all right let's take another
second to look at good chance who looks
like a kid do I look like a kid I know I
do what are my future goals don't I see
another person nice I love it
what are my future goals well I mean I
love working for the club and I love
doing being involved with chess I
unfortunately don't have enough time to
take two weeks off to go play
tournaments cuz them pre-med students
biology and Health Sciences and
hopefully medical school so yeah I am i
I actually used to be W I am 2014-15 or
not only 2015-2016 I was doubly GM
already and then I am fun fact I did
have all of the woman titles I had that
we CM started from the bottom then wfm
then I double you I am WGN I am yeah it
would be nice to have Jim in the
collection but yeah a little might be a
little too far out of reach right now
what is the biggest difference between
like 19 mm with the twenty one twenty
two hundred uh honestly I think I really
I think that was Jacob Tigre Grave who
asked that I think at least in my eyes
and for myself when I was twenty when I
was thinking about when I was like
nineteen hundred and I was trying to
cross through to twenty-one twenty-two
hundred for me it really felt like
understanding more strategy and more
psychology and chest really really helps
like just how to tink instead of just
starting to calculate something and also
improving my openings I feel like better
openings and better slightly better
overall understanding of the chest
doesn't necessarily mean like there's
super good and endgame or something
but yeah I do think I do think knowing
openings knowing your own openings what
you don't you're doing where your pieces
are supposed to be what are
like little tricks I feel like those are
some stuff that's what's helped you
across a level also having a good coach
that usually helps too all right we are
gonna continue playing it's not a Q&A
even though that's one two you should do
that one all right
there is a Reza who is kind of I can't
find oh it did fine all right let's see
how this goes again I do like increments
but we'll make an exception caro-kann
it's been a while since I've played
someone played the caro-kann online
against me this one is this one was one
of my favorite moves it's kind of easy
planned to follow and it gives you
instant like it slightly strategy edge
because you would be going for the sky
so I feel like that's something to look
forward to because like if h6 you see
then this Bishop 96 Panji 6 is already
looking a little on ease instead of 97
therefore there are some other lines to
go with like East 656 and Queen c7
immediately so there's that alright so
let's think about it objectively this
pawn should be falling ejected Lee now
it's just a matter of how to do it
does this simply work I'm talking both
pawns and queen of six seems to be the
only way to keep trying keep both palms
I like it let's go for it
again might not be the most accurate way
to play this but it really seems pretty
fun to play it
give me some key files on stuff but if
if I've I could do like 94 probably
oh maybe should be six attacking tonight
some of the interesting ideas
you're very very fast funny was the Andy
I would refer you to my TED talk for
that TEDx talk for your very insightful
question and the answer is absolutely
not biologically not and again I would
refer you to my TEDx talk
all right let's see long cast all it
also has its own little tricks because
if I take like on e6 10 rupees is simply
pinning its yeah 94 maybe but like Queen
takes d4 you know what let's not play
too fancy let's keep it real I'm gonna
protect this pawn that might be getting
attacked soon might have some cool ideas
with 94 now all right let's do this
what's bound to happen now if I 5 then I
can take and d7 Knight is kind of in a
pickle ooh
I don't think this was the smartest way
to go because now you're kind of like
kind of like weenie 7 or queen afraid to
defend the bishop
okay do we want to take this guy yeah
why not
free pawns are always appreciated it
should be a way of life now I can even
take this guy to g7
ah running away with the bishop I likes
it there I could take it
I really want to bring out my pieces
better
alright let's try this might regret it
but I really want to open up the stroke
and you kind of I feel like you kind of
had to take it because of e-cigs pong
I think I'm right I hope I'm right
probably Bishop e6 was a smarter oops
happens now I'm going for this guy which
you didn't let me it's okay I can
maneuver around a little now attacking
you go away
all right now doing some other attacks
fun stuff huh
hmm
let's go for this it's about time whoa
whoa
all right well yeah this is interesting
another thing that I thought of to
answer the differences between levels is
also like finding the like patience and
steady moves instead of the craziest
moves because sometimes the craziest
moves to pay off and it's pretty cool to
do those but not necessarily those are
always what the position needs all right
I don't
where are smothered mates Bishop 67 no
Queen d6 then one
Oh answering another question all right
that is true animate is good also any
piece piece up is good too
I like being piece up
and see a 0 64 sounds funny enough now I
get to be wet again
when is a good time to sacrifice risky I
mean it's more like an I would I kind of
think it depends on your position maybe
something like if you were out it really
depends on your position on your on your
chest style so if you're a super tactic
risky player don't listen to me you go
to tactics it really depends on your
personal chest style but usually it's
it's a nice idea to I mean if you see it
attack like a nice sacrifice why not I'm
usually not the biggest fan of risky
sacrifices and also how would you define
the risky sacrifice because like there
are some sacrifices that you can do and
there are more like dynamic like you
sacrifice something like it's night for
two pounds and even though you're not
meeting it's a still your position is
better it's more dynamic you sacrifice
something for complications I think
that's that's a good sacrifice a risky
sacrifice that you still can have like
compensation yeah why not go for it
0-60 for knows his openings or her
openings
that's kind of new to me sorry I haven't
played p3 in a while that's not new
whoops Jesus I think is the more common
way to go but
whoo I had a pretty nice game a while
ago in this I don't know with my night
on f5
oops
risky play is a scotch on the rocks
shaken not stirred Mr Bond
set miss please chat oh nice all right I
am NOT a big scotch man but I'll keep
that in mind
all right what are you trying to do
exchange it all off
can I reject it yes that's the big
question
I see some crazy stuff I really want to
try them probably shouldn't you really
do all right I'll see how this pays off
okay
probably night before Queen before 92-93
doable if not before why can't I just
play a 335 there de five
I think might be six is relatively the
safest choice but
kingi one is legal oh wow
I know it's legal but is it good gd1
look so suspicious what's wrong with my
feets you
I know king d1 was not for this position
because I was said with the way but
interesting
all right so Huck what should black too
do by thanking
what would idly well 96 I guess that's
something that I would have done unless
you see something super clear
was it time to do short Gaston yeah I
guess so
sorry long Castille and still yes I
guess so
I mean something like II takes f6 was
also interesting to consider but if take
back well no sorry not take back I was
kind of worried that some Bishop comes
out and some aruki 8i will take on it
six if you give me the chance now not
kidding ya see
sick this guy with the Queen I'll my
initial it is that if you move the
bishop
I might take thick pawn yeah that's true
c5 is interesting but well not after
long cast though because Queen see if I
would be with check where are you going
ah here all right
I'm upon up let's wrap it up exchange
the Queen's pretty pretty please
stick with the Queen some it's also
attacking your guy take the Queen take
the Queen so I can take back
you my friend are thinking way too much
unless you're having internet problems
oh well run out of time I mean the ends
game after Queen takes D to rook takes T
to is favors for whites specially
because to bishops is that these two
pawns running wild so yeah that's kind
of that was interesting it's been a
while since I got into this line
especially with long castle and f6 but
this is really I liked it it was
interesting thanks I yeah uh let's see
do we have any other interesting I'm a
pawn grabber of course haven't you been
following my games today
well some stuff about Magnus and Bing
and yeah that's for another time they're
all super grandmasters they're gonna
keep beating each other up and enjoying
it and winning and drawing and Wow so my
bet is Magnus will stay real champion
for two more years next candidate next
World Championship match let's see who
wins the candidates that'll be fun yeah
where are you follow clicking follow I
only do Instagram not a Twitter guy girl
yeah well that is kind of AI that's kind
of all the time we have for today but
this was fun and I kind of hope that we
have an interesting chat and interesting
games again next week and yeah this is
this was really nice I hope you guys
enjoyed it and see you next week
you